So the audio system in Unreal Engine 5 is something that the team has been working on
for a very long time.
It's a very powerful tool.
Synthesize power is how we're referring to it.
The audio engine inside of Unreal has had a big overhaul since the previous versions
of Unreal.
And we can, on the base level of Unreal Engine 5, you can support sound waves.
And that sound wave is essentially the default data imported, maybe imported, maybe created
directly inside the engine.
But we've got the wave data and the sound cues will hold these waves and you can edit
the waves through controls.
So in the previous workshop, we created a quick material with a metal and roughness.
And we created a base material and created a material instance from that material.
I like to think of sound cues as that base material and the waves are the kind of child
to that.
So in the sound cues, you will add waves.
So it's that kind of relationship.
All waves can be found in sound cues, but not all waves need sound cues.
I hope that's a useful way to describe it.
We have Quartz inside of Unreal Engine, which is sample accurate to all the timings that
are happening inside of your interactive experiences.
We can create music systems through clocks and metronomes.
And it also has full blueprint integration.
So you can, if you're doing any kind of real time interactions and you want certain inputs
to be registered to create SFX or music from, you can do that through the visual scripting
tool, which is a really powerful feature.
When we're thinking about meta sounds, we're thinking about replacing the sound cues and
having these larger meta sounds, which can have as simple or as complex scripting as
you need.
But essentially meta sounds are digital signal processing, a DSP, rendering graph, which
has a complete synth creation.
There's many demos out about meta sounds.
It's a really powerful tool for users of Unreal Engine to be digging into.
And it's something very exciting to look forward to developing more in the future.